ben wants to bring that warriors style
to his team go for to every time what do
you think of that philosophy the
bringing the splash the splash brother
philosophy to the NFL huh yeah you know
I think there's something there's ty
stone to be set for it especially now
that they move the extra point you know
back to being what is still a very high
percentage kick for a lot of kickers and
yet it does add some more variability I
think there's some people that would
argue that you would go for it on fourth
down a majority of the time as well and
again I think it's depending depending
upon the offense that you're in and the
guys that you have but certainly the
weapons that the steelers have maybe
they should be going for it on fourth
down and going for to every time I think
everybody would love to see that okay
but if you were given full autonomy that
you could do whatever you wanted to do
fourth down going for two point
conversion what would you do that's a
good question well I think personally I
feel like if we went for two that we
could make it more than fifty percent of
the time and I think fourth down
depending on where you are on the field
I feel like if you're in a manageable
situation we could we could convert most
fourth downs so I'm all for it you're
gonna tell coach peyton about that well
it's his decision but i don't i don't
need to tell coach peyton to be more
aggressive I think we got that I think
we got that that part of it is it Kara
is it easier for a rookie quarterback
coming in now or tougher well I think
they're more prepared now than they ever
have been and you can attribute that to
probably any number of things I think
you look at the look at what the
opportunities are for high school
quarterbacks now nowadays that that
we're not there let's say when I was
coming out of high school these seven on
seven passing
leagues and the amount of time and
commitment that they put towards playing
the game and mastering the game in their
position is infinitely more now than it
was you know even ten years ago then you
get to college and I feel like there's
so much carryover and crossover with
coaching and with systems from college
to NFL you get colleges or coaches that
have been at both levels and basically
run the same system now obviously the
amount of time that you put into it at
the NFL level is much greater than
college you know you're limited with you
know kids got to go to class and they're
limited to a certain number of hours per
week on the field in college and spring
ball and that kind of thing whereas NFL
to full-time job but bottom line is by
the time guys get to the NFL they they
have put probably thousands of more
hours into their craft than you know
guys ten years ago so yes I believe that
they are more prepared now defenses
continue to evolve offenses continue to
evolve so the complexity is maybe a bit
more as well so that requires more time
on task but man I think guys are more
prepared now to come into this game and
be successful than ever before at the
quarterback position especially what was
your welcome to the NFL moment you know
I remember I was really it was it was
practice because when i got to the
charters in 2001 they had junior sale
and rodney harrison on defense which to
this day I've never seen two guys
practice prepare and play like those two
every day was game day for those guys
whether you had pads on or not and their
intensity and just their emotion and the
way that they competed each and every
day was was awesome it was unbelievable
I mean they they were football players
and they were leaders and man they they
set the bar so i'll always remember
those two guys as being really
influential on my career
here and especially that first year just
be an eye-opening like wow this is the
NFL and those type of guys that I got to
go up against now he's Drew Brees saints
quarterback joining us Dan Patrick shell
well congratulations you made one of my
guys cry with your courtyard commercial
was that the goal the the Father's Day
video was that the goal to make people
make guys crying well it was it was
supposed to honor fathers all across the
country who no matter what you do you're
working extremely hard and trying to be
the best you know husband father that
you can possibly be and at times that
takes us away from our families but just
to just as a tribute to let father's
around the country know just how much
they're loved by their families and
their kids and myself and Vince Wilfork
and Ryan Kalil and Antonio Brown we all
had a chance to sit back and watch our
kids talk about us on camera and you
know it's always interesting to see what
your kids will say you know because you
feel like you you try to impart so much
on them even at a very early age you
know whenever something happens in life
when I'm with the kids and I feel like
it's a teaching moment I try to tell
them a story or give them a lesson out
of it and you know sometimes they give
you that kind of glazed look and you're
not sure if it's going in one ear and
out the other they're retaining it but
bottom line is I think they see and feel
so much so much more than you could ever
imagine and so all of a sudden when you
get them in front of a camera and they
have a chance to talk about you and talk
about you know their dad and what their
dad means to them the things they love
doing with their dad I mean that really
that puts it all in perspective and it
truly makes you realize that being a
father is the greatest responsibility we
have as a male is the absolute greatest
responsibility and so I take so much
pride in it I love doing this this piece
with courtyard I think we're yard so
much for putting it together because it
was uh it was really a great opportunity
to just share that love with my kids and
of course one
of your son says his favorite players
Cam Newton well he says that is when
asked what their favorite team is I had
two of them said to New York Giants and
one of them say the Carolina Panthers so
that's that's Odell Beckham jr. coming
into play here as well yeah yeah yeah so
you know I don't know where gets into
these kids heads be honest with you
actually I know that the New York Giants
one was Balon and Bowen so those two go
to newman here in New Orleans which is
where Eli and Odell Beckham both went to
school so there's a little bit of you
know just kind of school pride loyalty I
tried to tell them blood is thicker than
water but they didn't quite get that yet
and then Callen my youngest who is like
super loyal to dad you know when asked
what favorite what his favorite number
was he said Oh dad's number number nine
they're like oh what's your favorite
team Karolina it's right I'm just gonna
have to take it out on it on them in the
yard when they want to try to play
football with me or basketball wow did
you see this story remember the Buffalo
Bills Carlos Williams running back he
put on 25 pounds when his wife was
pregnant he said he put on the pounds
because his wife was pregnant he ate
with her Jimmy is that a goodie close
yeah um that might that might just be an
excuse to like if my wife said you know
honey I'm you know I'm going to gain 30
pounds in this pregnancy and you got to
gain it with me and you have to eat
chicken fried steak and and all this
stuff every day in order to do that it'd
be like okay that sounds great I'm going
to do that yeah I might not not have to
be talked into that that I might jump
right on board yeah well the
quarterbacks are all in a health kick
now Aaron Rodgers giving up cheese
Brady's gotta cook book I mean you you
maintain pretty good shape as well yeah
listen here's my theory is everything in
moderation you know you just don't go
overboard with anything yeah I try to
eat as healthy as I possibly can but do
i do I have
my my splurge moments you know maybe
that's one time a week where you know
I'm going to eat how many a donut or I'm
going to eat or my chicken fried steak
or something like that yeah absolutely
cuz i think it's life's little pleasures
like that and kind of that you know that
opportunity just to be normal you know
and but for the most part yeah I'm on a
strict regimen I mean I'm very
disciplined when it's time to be
disciplined but also no one is to you
know time to have a good time and again
everything in moderation how do people
get a chance to see the videos with
courtyard you know what they're all over
YouTube and they're all over the social
media channels so just uh if you can
follow me at a drew brees on Twitter
Facebook and all the guys that are
involved Vince Wilfork Ryan Kalil
Antonio Brown and then courtyard as well
we'll be posting videos obviously we did
it yesterday but we'll be doing it all
the way up to father's day great should
talk to you drew have a good Father's
Day thanks for joining us I dad thank
you the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience